what is
life this particular thing we got going
on here this pocket of complexity that
emerged from such simple things yeah
it's a tough question i asked that
question even to uh richard dawkins
and i already have my preconceived
notion which he pretty much confirmed
which is
if one could give an answer to that
question that allowed you to sort of
draw a line in the sand between the not
living and the living then perhaps we
would have the insight that we yearn for
and trying to say what is so special
about life but the fact of the matter is
it's a continuum there's a continuum
from the things that we would typically
call non-living inanimate to the things
that we obviously call animate and full
of the currents of life
somewhere in there
it is a question of the complexity of
the structure the ability of the
structure to take in raw material from
the environment and process it through a
metabolism that allows the structure to
extract energy and to release entropy to
the wider environment
somewhere in those collections of
biological processes is
the
necessity or the necessary ingredients
and processes for life but
drawing that line in the sand is not
something that we're able to do but i
would agree with you
it's deeply
peculiar
it may in fact be unique
but it may not it could be that
the universe is such that under fairly
typical conditions a star
that's
a well-ordered source of low entropy
energy that's what the sun is together
with a planet being bathed by that low
entropy energy together with a surface
that has enough of the
raw constituents that we recognize are
fairly commonplace result of supernova
explosions where star
spews forth the result of the nuclear
furnace that is the core of a star it
could be
that all you need are those fairly
commonplace conditions
and maybe life naturally forms like the
james webb space telescope right is
going up hopefully in december and one
of the one of the goals of that mission
is to look at atmospheres around distant
planets and perhaps come to some sense
of how special or not
life or leaf life as we know it is in
the universe
you